好多人对付业的理解都是错的
这就是你为什么做不好付业的原因
其实你现在的组业
你现在的公司很可能是你的天使投资人
但是很多人搞错了
大部分人都管
工作当中了说
我我是华世间来赚钱的地方
我老闆的摩鱼
我怎么做才能
才能华算
但是这一上如果你一转念的话你会发现
原来做服务业这么简单
给大家介绍两个方法
两个基本的方法
让你做服务的成功率变得越来越高
首先第一个方法就是
我们很多人把主业和付业
对立了
甚至很多人
做服务的原因就是因为
逃了一主业
对吧
这个时候你是很难做成的
为什么呢
因为你本人做了自己不喜欢做的事情
你有些时候还会把一种
不快乐也算在这个组织的头上
但是你要想通过付业的问题
你得做的特别好
对吧你有经常立才过业但是
你很难有经常立嘛
平时你的时间又不够嘛对不对
这个时候你又没有办法做的特别好所以你付业永远开担不出来
但是如果你把念头转一下
主业和付业不少也可以
他不是想对的
他是互捕的又会怎么样呢
给大家讲个例子
我是在1617年吧
这个事实发生的一个月起年
他就知道我来到视频之前我是给一些企业组成功问的
然后有一些企业
一些大盘
会停过去
长年的企业情供去他们公司去分享
然后就会认识他们一些企业的一些人
有些就成了朋友
然后有一次吃饭的时候
做完自选吃饭的时候
当时一个朋友就替到他说
胡同我是特别羡慕你
对吧你又做你自己喜欢的事
然后时间又特别地冲冲雨
我说你也可以啊他说我不信
我喜欢的这个事不能帮我赚钱
我说你喜欢什么事呢
他说我喜欢美妆
喜欢打扮自己
他许当时说这个特别高级的才我想不想的大概也就是我喜欢美妆
我喜欢装扮自己
我你看确实是
他很会穿搭吗对吧发穿搭
我说你可以接着做呀
你可以做面在就花这个时间去研究他呀
他怎么拥有我是你该
该上班上班
然后有空的时间你就
你就去做你自己感兴趣的事吗你对他感兴趣吗你就愿意花时间吗
他就做这个
然后他干嘛呢
就是他确实特别会穿搭
所以他的一些不做变的朋友同事啊都会
都会就是请教他
后来他就在朋友圈发了的消息说
我命远非给大家分享
怎么穿搭
然后就变成了一个活动固定的活动刚开始的话哪个几个人后来人越来越多
后来他们不是不但他们公司的人啊周边的公司的人都会
就是去请他去做分享
后来他的这个富裔其实远远超过了他的主义的收入
没有理事
没有理事然后问他我说
后来我问他他说
其实我现在发现
我们也很快乐
因为我做我其实我也丢不举仿然我都能了
我只是没有做我自己洗盘子的事
现在我
这边工作了然后下班可以
做我洗做我的那个洗盘子的事本来我工作也不是很忙
昨晚每天特别的快乐
我不需要此次是我也不需要闯你有这么多点干嘛
我工作又很清甜又不是很
不是很忙
最练还可以做最练喜欢的事
所以各位其实你的主义和富裔是可以相互
交容的
比如说你原来的工作都是做那好了
现在可以尝试用脑
你像我以前原来是尝试用脑
大家都知道了我尝试用脑
后来的话我就开电话话
我还穿电了BTC
然后还搞了习惧事
还搞了各种感染游戏
我是
做脑的然后开始搞
做叶育的时间就搞
用脑
但其实你会发现他俩融合起来以后
就让我更有闯脑了因为先尝试用脑是很似乱的吗
有的这个
只好所以很多人都认为我不是尝试用啊其实我不但不是尝试
是吃生尝试
你原来工作是体力的那你可以做脑力的
以前是劳力的那你可以做体力的对吧你原来是劳力的劳动啊
那你下班可以去专门健身啊专门做余家啊对吧这尝的一些
一些活动所以你看你的组业和服务也是
后悔的
之后悔的他不是不是后试的
然后你就会发现你就不会那号对吧你看我很尊做服务也是那号
哎呀主义也没做好很焦慮
这个服务也没做成阿洋每天就很焦慮很焦慮但你这个时候就会发现变得快乐的这是低于中啊就是你的组业和服务业其实可以互务的
第二时候就有意思了这借传出海
什么意思呢
就是你的主业不但不是你负业的主艾而且你的主业是你负业的天死投资的
是你免费的萨学院和
资源库啥意思给大家举个例子啊我在写家这些法的时候你家这些法呢
我家这些家这些法的时候想过这个事啊就是我当时是给一个大型企业国企
当时在河北八州
然后呢当通讯员很多事不是我的分辈制是分分内之事啊比如说什么打击灌了怎么击灌了怎么击灌了怎么击灌了怎么击灌了都不是我的分辈制
九八年九九年的时候那个时候网站还没那么流行
但是我觉得我们应该网站像像我们两个企业
很传闯网站的不行我要我要搞这个网站
当时从八州到北京我做车过来
一个半老师
其实到了北京中恩村的本来还要是了啊
当时冬恩村的到数多买低的有买熟的大衡
我就会自己买很多数包括光片这做的什么而且还健康啊
所以在此他这俩是非不在
自己买很多数然后一边学一边做
然后去问了啊我不知道现在是不是办了啊当时说办了啊然后买了那个夭明很祝福的福气
根本没跟公司打招呼
就是自己做一点一年做
我们公司整个的网站就是我自己搭下来的
阿芳那以后才跟公司说
很多人说你傻呀 对吧
话词的钱 话词的时间给公司干涉
我从来不这么想
各位你们知道吗
你自己独一双叶最难的是什么
是你的试错成本
你说我死之我就搬一个事情
你没干成怎么办
对对对
但是你回发现你换了角度
就是我这个时候
我虽然华到我自己的时间华到我自己的钱
然后我去做这样的一件事情
那你会发现我做完了以后的公司看
公司就知道这提好的
对不对
相当于公司是我的第一个用户了
那么我这个能力是被的断连出来的
那公司说这个不行
不用不了这个
不赛以后无所谓
什么啥
什么我这个好像
还多亏我党是没创意
什么
我还能回到以前的公司
所以你明白吗
有些时候
公司
你就换个角度
不是你华时间然后赚钱的地方
他是老板华钱
让你免费
华钱不是免费
不但当你华钱
还让你得去进修的地方
你想问没有
在扩展一下给点减个
大家都知道的
还没用戏一打给查一下
就是有一个姑娘
叫卡特怒多
这个还有没有这个的案例
当时是什么呢
是给一家资用公司一个很普通的资源
然后
他的工作的干嘛呢
就是给客户加音效
你想
苏群公司里料给客户加音效
和既然这个小姑娘
资资资并不高
而且做的工作也不是特别重要的工作
对了这种所谓的
编较料的工作
很多人都不愿意做
对了他就去做了
然后小姑娘可能也愿意想
然后就陪运一个效嘛
每次都是讲一个效价的音效
他怎么可能讲得更好呢
你讲得不好人就不愿意听吗
他就各种媒体测误
各种想法去讲
然后后来他就把一些讲的东西
发到TX套上TX套
然后他的粉丝越来越来越多越来越多
然后他数也得收入远远就超过了他的主义
所以各位你们体会一下
就是你的主义和你的服务也不但不相处
你的主义反而会成为你的免费的上学院
和你监视的胡嘴对吧
所以你就想哎
我现在我现在这个主义是什么
就是老板的套钱
让我的这免费惊求的
所以有些时候在你的工作中
一些所费的一些困难的事情
很可能就是你的第一统计
你只要穿越过去
这种你的第一统计
然后你认真做成了一件事
可能就是你的第一个传统
所以各位
当你把工作当作一个生意的时候
你不再为公司公司的时候
你的工作才开始帮你赚钱